[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live i love podcast
lords of gaming.net
in the realm of pax who is this fine
gentleman that we have in the realm
today hey guys my name is mario i'm a
head of a studio cool to play studio and
we are here to show you your gun
yeah a really awesome artisan top-down
shooter okay and now i'm pretty excited
yeah i will show it to you let's check
this out man let's check out euro gun
top-down shooter yeah tell us a little
bit about this game this looks really
cool let's get right into it yeah yeah
it's like you know you can imagine you
are kind of inside of a mecca system you
know okay you can see uh yeah you are a
mac in this game you play as a mac okay
uh kind of a you know conscious in a
thinking machine okay and you wake up
from a long slumber
somewhere in the future not so distant
future
where things went really bad like you
know environmental disasters and a
apocalypse okay it's a fact actually and
humanity is gone okay your dear pilot is
gone okay you don't know what happened
you're just trying to find her you're a
pilot yeah so we'll wake up yeah you
wake up after this long slumber and
trying to fight her and uh let's see
yeah right into it okay nice so that's
it yeah uh
so top top down controls exactly yeah
and the movement like this is what you
learned down uh the movement was like
really crucial important part to us
because we want this whole like you know
game shooting game we took kind of a
like a dance you know okay like a movie
okay yeah you just move down and up like
you move towards enemies then you're
like high and then you know find a
better position so uh yeah the movement
was really important and uh yeah we
nailed it in this game you you can see
that absolutely um and this is like a
little bit of the story here where you
can find a computer and
uh ai uh you know uh written by the
humans that somehow survived this ai
apocalypse okay and uh this ai is gonna
you know guide you through the world and
help you find your planet yeah this will
be an ai that will be consistent
throughout the world yeah yeah exactly
it's one of the you know characters of
the game
you are the mac you're a protagonist and
this is kind of your you know french
sidekick yeah yeah okay
you have this relation as a machine to
machine but those machines have a little
bit of character you know nice so uh
yeah you can see that you know uh
through the narrative nice uh but yeah
let's uh first things first yeah let's
uh let's set up the systems let's uh get
your weaponry system back online yeah i
want to see some weapons yeah
you're going to need this because this
is next looks cool yeah and i need to
use the webroot exactly and i love the
boost mechanic yeah oh wow so you can
even use it for traversal yeah over
there exactly traversing over the gap
destroying the stuff in the world
you can do it with the boots yeah
and this is the place where you get your
weapons back online yeah
right now ai is trying to help us yeah
yeah she's saying like yeah probably
this will work but there's this like
chance you know of risk here but yeah oh
so we gotta look like a little tart type
gun situation exactly yeah yeah your
hand is your gun yeah i'm liking that
yeah and this is your first gun you have
is a classic minigun yes this has given
me robocop 8209. oh yeah i'm loving it
i'm loving it
yeah actually the design of the mecca is
kind of a similar to the evil mech from
the rubber counter
the one that fell down the stairs you
have 10 seconds to comply yeah exactly
maybe you notice there was some shiny
stuff yes that comes off the enemies and
this is heat and you can use this heat
to your advantage and this is short here
on the ui those orange dots once you
fill one you can use it for healing now
yeah this is one of the systems for the
game
uh you can use this kit for healing and
later on in game you will learn how to
use it offensively right so you have
this kind of a tactical choice between
shooting and and healing and healing
attacking and uh attacking defense so
the offensive defense component with it
with the heat that's not one resource
and it also influences other mechanics
that you'll see soon overdrive mechanics
so the more you use the heat attack
offensively the faster you build your
combo got it yeah and you will see that
in in a second and now you have a second
weapon we got a rocket launcher so this
is like a classical bed with dual
wielding and you can use them both
simultaneously nice you know this is
kind of a cool uh and unique mechanics
for the game
because games rarely do that yes we want
you to be like fully in control of your
arsenal although you know there are some
mechanics like you know you cannot shoot
this rocket launcher all the time the
clip size is free so you have to manage
you know ammo no i'm assuming is there
also like a cool down aspect of it
exactly exactly so you have to master it
so you know use it wisely but uh yeah
don't save it for later just use it
twice nice and then the rocket launcher
is really effective towards shields okay
yeah okay so uh it's it's wise to use
rocket launcher against children
yeah and this is the end of the first
like you know tutorial mission
um each mission gives you some rewards
like new guns mods for the guns speed
attacks uh
expansion cartridges so you can build up
your mecha the way you like it so yeah
with each mission you get a lot of this
and also a support awesome now let me
ask you this now i'm loving the weapon
choices i'm loving the diversity of the
attacks offensive defensive yeah now are
there specific will there'll be specific
like builds like from a mexico like one
person could play a specific neck a
specific way with with different weapon
sets versus another person that may go
all defensive like how expansive is the
the weapons and the way you build out a
mech you you will see that in a while uh
i'm gonna get you to the first real
mission now uh we're gonna explore heat
attacks and uh overdrive system and then
i'm gonna show you like different biome
we can go to hong kong or
we've got different biomes yeah that's
the first one this is barcelona i like
post-apocalyptic barcelona san diego
sunburn and then we have like rain in
stormy hong kong or on the rooftops and
we also have like ice northern cascades
nice and we can go there on
those three biomes in our early access
version of the game that has been
launched a week ago
and i'll show you those violence with
different weapon sets
so let's go to the first mission yep
check it out buy on time
we're checking it out
uh yeah
we got our mini gun okay
we got this minigun and a rocket
launcher we can heal ourselves
and soon we're going to discover some
more stuff yeah i'm seeing enemies left
now this is i'm assuming like ford
mechanic we have to clear this thing out
yeah exactly and we have like different
objectives uh around the game uh part of
them just like uh you know kill them all
objective some of them are like you know
uh hold the position or huck
or like pick up and deliver so we have
like different objectives that you know
have some different vibe and to your
tactics along the game loving loving the
art style and one thing that's really
cool is like in the age where you don't
see top-down shooters as much
i just love the fact that it gets that
classic feel that classic gameplay feel
gameplay right here because i love the
engine are that
design choice in the art style yeah yeah
uh we are
producing this game using unity
yeah and uh we spent a lot of time you
know stylizing this game because uh it's
a kind of a homage to the classic arcade
shooters
slightly more also you know like a
skylight and stuff so yeah happy happy
to hear that so what's this overdrive
yeah the overdrive it's like you see
this you know um you're right in the top
left corner so this is your combo you'll
build this combo with shooting to
enemies and not getting hit so if you're
not getting hit uh your multiplier chain
is building up
just you know uh charging this overdrive
faster nice once it's charged you can
enter into kind of a bullet time
you know okay so you are moving super
fast to super strong with the advantage
yeah exactly and you can use it like you
know to get out from
uh exactly and we're gonna do it now
yeah check it out so this is it this is
the overdrive system okay yeah getting a
little bullet time on slow down more
powerful attack exactly and we have the
speed again
yeah yeah uh you can dash uh almost you
know without a cooldown so we are really
you know mobile those are for those
clutch situations when the health is low
and things like that now let me ask you
this because again loving everything
you're doing right now loving how the
game is progressing this is intel okay
intel is a resource that allows you to
modify your mechanic so you collect it
uh on the missions it's hidden sometimes
it's hidden sometimes it's like you know
just in front of you
uh oh yeah you just have to go
the climate situation and this is like
the mecca chords that you can absorb and
you can absorb this system to um
uh to enhance your mac to build your mac
yeah we look like we're pulling this
over other destroyed mechs yeah and
we're getting those resources exactly
exactly that's good let's try it out
let's download the data yeah
this chart yeah
discharge uh and this is the other way
of using this kit
you see now i can use it just to you
know
so once you're a corner you know with
enemies or something you can get out
with these yeah here's the thing how
many skills can you have active at a
time or the situation where we need to
switch uh well uh you switch in between
missions okay now uh with different
builds now you can have equip like two
weapons with different with up to three
mods each and you will see this soon and
two heat attacks plus repair so it's
like two weapons and three skills i
would say yeah
let's go into the bullet we're going
through the
now from a narrative standpoint will it
be a situation like um as you progress
in the game when you start finding out
more about the character and if so
in what manner is the story going to be
told to the player yeah uh the story yes
yes we have like yeah narrative we have
like two ways to to tell the story so
far the first one you saw like uh those
little dialogues between the mac and ola
this ai system yeah
uh and the other way is to find
uh comic pages they are just scattered
around the world
and those comic pages are a kind of a
retrospective to the missions okay so
you can see like what happened before
disaster yeah oh so like like you're
going back in the past on that mission
exactly yeah exactly yeah
yeah gotcha so the thing i want to know
is from already from a platform
standpoint you know what are we looking
at getting euro going on so i'm very
curious yeah uh
now it's available on steam uh some
early access we are planning to develop
it for the next six to 12 months
depending on the reception and the
feedback and this is our goal after we
release uh uragan on steam it will risk
also on other platforms and port it to
the console and handheld it already
works on a steam deck it plays
beautifully
yeah it plays beautifully on the steam
deck and it's like really good game for
the handheld so yeah a lot of fun as far
as development how long have you guys
been in development
um it's around two years for now yeah
with some pivoting on the way so
it's not an easy answer to this question
yeah yeah that's really cool now do we
have another biome yeah yeah yeah let's
go to hong kong baby yes one more one
okay so let's go to hong kong and i'll
show you some sick new weapons maybe oh
let's do that yeah with uh with the new
skills yeah okay let's do that
all right let's travel to hong kong
so you know this minigun um
it's it's buffed now like it's it's just
triple you know serious and what about
the other arm and the other one is a
plasma disc it's like a boomerang it
goes back and it leaves like this you
know trail of flames
your mecca is also boosted with the
projectile deflection and once enemies
shoot at you you can boost and just
deflect the projectiles oh yeah awesome
and you have like uh
i just briefly you have like energy
sword
and you can also jump onto enemies yeah
nice
mechanic yeah sword yeah you're really
pumped we are really expanding the field
one thing i did want to ask you from
somewhere
are there bosses in europe yeah yeah uh
we have like many buses and we have like
a big big bosses you know in this game
nice uh there is like a sandworm
centipede boss in barcelona okay that
you can play with oh no no this one
but look at this look at this i'll jump
on him
man loving loving the art style loving
the abilities yeah and the diverse the
diversity of the weapons is pretty cool
yeah it is cool actually yeah
obviously
getting these spiders out of here
they're already too
late we get more intel with an enhanced
gift of community exactly exactly
exactly
okay
yeah for traversal
nice
so that energy sword come out yeah
exactly you can just you know crush
everyone who's standing in front of you
yeah it's like really good to
move around and yeah awesome man yeah
really loving the vibe
so cool
euro gun
i'm feeling man if were feeling it we're
feeling it
definitely it's really fun to play like
for us it was really important that the
shooting is you know nice and uh and the
weapons are cool and you just can feel
powerful
so yeah it's all the race for the power
in this game and you know feel good
moments now long term so as far as like
game hours length what can a person
expect
yeah so now it's like two and a half up
to three hours during early access and
we plan somehow to double on that you
know for the single period campaign we
also plan to add some challenges okay
you know now you said single player
family yeah yeah because is there a
possibility that maybe in the future
maybe in the future
mode as well maybe in the future yeah
some kind of a challenge mode where you
can play with your friend you know build
up the score and you know
just do it jumping together and
crushing enemies together man yeah so
look you heard it here first is there is
there
like is there a way that you're going to
be able to play as the mech and your
pilot or being able to traverse between
the two
stay with one well to be honest yeah uh
we still haven't decided on that
because i mean what would be really cool
also yeah is if you get some master
blaster action and you can yeah
yeah
there we go
you know yeah
still exploring we are really open to
you know any cool solution for this game
we like the setting that you know you
have this relationship with your pilot
yes and uh you were kind of a friends
before so we'll definitely explore more
in that yeah
so tell the people for your gun they
want to support it they want to get more
information yeah what could the people
in the realm do yo you know guys and
girls just you know
you can join our discord server uh you
can be up to date with you know all the
cool stuff that is going on and
development we are trying to develop
this game with you together so just join
us and share your feedback and opinion
we we are really curious to see how you
like this game yeah and uh you can also
buy it on steam early access and leave a
comment on his team it's really valuable
to us so yeah please just share your
comments and share your feedback you're
already here first you'll call them your
gun share your feedback they got a
discord server they're on steam check it
out go get out the early access that's
available now yeah it is right and go
check it out again euro gun one of the
ones to watch it 209 twin stick shooter
vibes a lot of weapons colorful hostiles
you heard it here first an absolute
pleasure yeah they could have you in a
room yeah it's really cool to have you
yeah thanks
[Music]